lors de votre journal de l'Afrique soyez
les bienvenus si vous nous joignez sur
France 24 coups d'État au Burkina Faso
le lieutenant-colonel d'amyba était
évincé il est remplacé ce soir par le
capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré les frontières sont
désormais fermer les connexions sont
particulièrement difficiles avec le
Burkina Faso ont offera de joindre en
jeu nominaux il est sur place pour
France 24
vous l'aurez compris nous allons
consacrer une large partie de cette
édition à ce coup d'État a confirmé au
Burkina Faso le lieutenant-colonel
d'amyba et t’évincé du pouvoir après des
heures d'incertitude l'annonce a été
faite à la télévision publique vous
voyez ces images justement qui nous
parviennent de la capitale le
lieutenant-colonel d'ami m'a plu
président de la Transition c'est le
capitaine Ibrahim à Traoré qui doit
désormais le remplacer je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait de cette annonce
lieutenant-colonel Paul Henri Sandra
du mpsr
2 le capitaine Traoré Ibrahim est nommé
président du mpsr pour compter de ce
jour
avec nous au plateau bonsoir Khalidou
journal 24 vous avez vous-même été notre
correspondant Burkina Faso pendant
plusieurs années c'était peut-être une
question d'heure avant que cette annonce
elle ne soit officiellement faite vous
l'avez raconté tout au long de la
journée il y a eu plusieurs tirs
entendus aux abords du palais
présidentiel dans la journée et puis
cette annonce est finalement arrivé
assez tard dans dans la soirée c'est
désormais chose faite un coup d'État
dans le coup d'État et c'est le
capitaine Traoré qui est le nouvel homme
fort du Burkina Faso ce soir c'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre comme vous l'avez
dit Nadia c'est un coup d'état d'un coup
d'État la journée a été très longue à
Ouagadougou la journée était très longue
tout a commencé dans la nuit à 4h du
matin les premiers tirs ont retenti dans
le camp babassi à Ouaga 2000 et au
niveau de la présidence à ce moment-là
on se pose des questions on se demande
si c'est une mutinerie un coup d'état
par le passé
les coups d'État se sont fait certains
très rapidement d'autres ont pris plus
de temps souvenez-vous sur du 24 janvier
2022 Paul-Henri Sander celui qui a été
poutu aujourd'hui avait lui-même fait un
coup d'état un ancien président Kaboré
les premiers tirs nourris étaient le 23
janvier le dimanche matin mais le coup
d'État n'a été annoncé que le lendemain
soit à 17h donc presque un jour et demi
pour un coup d'état aujourd'hui ça a
pris moins de temps mais il y avait des
signes annonciateurs ces signes c'était
tous les ingrédients étaient réunis pour
le coup d'état vous connaissez les
ingrédients habituels pour le pour un
coup d'état la télévision nationale qui
est coupée de 1 le signal ensuite des
militaires dans la ville qui ont bloqué
des axes principaux et stratégiques
comme
la Primature comme le palais de la
présidence et la télévision nationale et
puis le on va dire le feu d'artifice
lorsqu'il y a un coup d'état c'est des
tirs mais lorsqu'il y a des tirs on peut
pas savoir qui tire envers qui si c'est
des affrontements ou des tirs de
sommation mais durant toute la journée
en Ouagadougou il a eu des tirs du côté
du gouvernement on a eu cette posture
c'est de la communication maintenant on
sait que c'était de la communication ou
peut-être que c'était vrai de dire que
au moment où j'ai contacté le
porte-parole du gouvernement on peut
dire maintenant de l'ancien gouvernement
Lionel Bigo c'est en milieu de journée
une ambigo me disait que c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des il y avait des à
malentendus mais c'était uniquement au
sein de l'armée et que le président
était en sécurité allait bien était en
train de négocier
dans la journée après l'après-midi il a
eu un calme plat et là beaucoup de
questions se posaient c'était une
situation qui était totalement opposée
au matin ce matin profusion
d'informations de l'intox des fake news
il fallait faire le tri puis
l'après-midi plus d'informations donc on
s'est posé beaucoup de questions et dans
la soirée visiblement ça c'est accéléré
des tirs ont repris qui aboutit à la
destitution de Paul-Henri Sando Damiba à
l'annonce de la télévision nationale
comme on a pu le voir et élu on l'a
aucun moment aperçu tout au long de la
journée aucune apparition publique
aucune déclaration de la part
directement
sur la page Facebook de la présidence un
communiqué qui disait que oui il y avait
la situation était tendue au Burkina
Faso mais que le président était
pour parler avec les mutins on parlait
de conflits internes à l'armée à aucun
moment il était question destitution
renversement de président de la
transition mais comme je vous l'ai dit
lorsque la télévision nationale est
coupée toute une journée lorsque des
militaires patrouillent dans la ville et
interdisent l'accès à certains axes
principaux et des tirs des tirs à l'arme
lourde au sein de la capitale c'est rare
que ça n'aboutisse pas un coup d'État et
un coup d'État dans le coup d'État je
vais le rappeler parce que le
lieutenant-colonel d'amyba avait
lui-même pris le pouvoir par la force en
janvier dernier vous le rappeliez à
juste titre Kalidou le renversait alors
le président Kaboré c'était il y a 8
mois on va revenir en images sur cet
événement là
coup de feu mutinerie couvre-feu le 24
janvier 2022 des militaires prennent le
pouvoir à Ouagadougou les puccistes
renversent le président élu rock Marc
Christian caboret alors tête le
lieutenant-colonel Paul-Henri sandao il
promet de faire de la sécurité sa
priorité dans un pays miné depuis 2015
par les attaques djihadistes et les
tensions communautaires
si les priorités sont nombreuses il est
clair que la priorité principale demain
la sécurité
il nous faut en effet réduire
significativement les zones sous
influence terroristes
et les impacts de l'extrémisme violent
l'homme fort de la gente militaire au
pouvoir depuis ne cependant pas réussi à
enrayer le cycle des violences les
attaques meurtrières de mouvements armés
affiliés à Al-Qaïda et au groupe état
islamique se sont poursuivis elles ont
fait des centaines de morts aussi bien
des civils que des militaires et
provoquer le déplacement de quelques 2
millions de personnes cette semaine
encore un convoi qui devait ravitailler
en vivre la ville de Djibo a été
attaquée par des djihadistes présumés en
soldats ont été tués 28 personnes
blessées et 56 villes sont toujours
portées disparus selon le dernier bilan
officiel d'autres attaques ont
particulièrement marqué l'opinion
publique comme le massacre de seitenga
en juin dernier lors duquel au moins 86
civils ont été exécutés plusieurs villes
du nord du pays sont même désormais
soumises à des blocus de djihadistes qui
font particulièrement sauter des ponts à
la dynamite et attaque des convois de
ravitaillement selon l'ongled le Burkina
Faso est devenu depuis l'an dernier
l'épicentre des violences dans le sel
avec plus d'attaques meurtrières comme
Ali ou au Niger
kalidon va revenir maintenant sur la
situation actuelle et les développements
de ces dernières heures on sait que les
frontières ont été fermées on sait que
les connexions sont particulièrement
difficiles on a nous-mêmes eu beaucoup
de mal à joindre nos équipes sur place
nous envoyer spéciaux qu'est-ce qui peut
se passer dans dans les prochaines
heures on a l'impression que c'est un
huis clos là qui est en train de se
créer autour de du pays les frontières
sont fermées comme vous l'avez dit les
institutions sont suspendues dans les
prochains jours je pense qu'il faudra
être attentif à la réaction de la CEDEAO
parce que vous l'avez vu lors du premier
coup d'État que le Burkina que
Paul-Henri Standard a fait le 25 janvier
dernier la CEDEAO a été un peu plus
patiente et conciliante avec le Burkina
Faso qu'avec le Mali prenant l'exemple
du Mali ou la Guinée
mais là c'est un coup d'État dans un
coup d'État comme ce qui s'est passé au
Mali
en juillet dernier c'est Étienne
exactement et là configuration d'un
double coup d'État
la CEDEAO pour être beaucoup plus sévère
pourrait sanctionner le Burkina Faso
dans les prochaines heures il y aura une
réaction d'accéder à qui n'a pas d'autre
choix et l'Union africaine mais à part
des mots ce sera quoi ce sera une
condamnation tout simplement ça
s'arrêtera là
condamner ce coup d'État c'est un coup
d'État n'est pas constitutionnel il sera
évidemment condamné par la Cedeao mais
pardon mais ce sont des mots est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir des sanctions
ça c'est une autre histoire tout d'abord
je pense que la CEDEAO va envoyer des
émissaires au Burkina Faso très
rapidement la semaine prochaine pour
rencontrer les poutisses et savoir leur
motivation ensuite pour avoir leur
feuille de route savoir s'ils vont
redonner le pouvoir aussi vivre ou il
souhaite s'installer dans une transition
de je ne sais combien de mois on va
réécouter une nouvelle fois cette
déclaration faite en direct à la
télévision pour vous téléspectateurs si
vous venez nous rejoindre il y a
quelques minutes je vous rappelle donc
cette actualité ce principal type de nos
éditions de ce soir coup d'État au
Burkina Faso après plusieurs heures
d'incertitude une annonce a été faite ce
soir à la télévision publique le colonel
d'ami ban n'est plus le président de
transition il est remplacé par le
capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré écoutez
le lieutenant-colonel Paul Henri Sandra
du mpsr
2 le capitaine Traoré Ibrahim est nommé
président du mpsr pour compter de ce
jour
c'est un militaire Kalidou qui prend la
place d'un autre militaire le grade de
capitaine pour
Ibrahim Traoré dont on a très peu
d'informations sur son parcours sur sa
personnalité sur ses motivations mais
quand bien même c'est un renversement
une trahison si je peux me permettre ce
mot de l'Intérieur à l'intérieur même du
corps militaire celui qui était
normalement aux ordres du
lieutenant-colonel Damiba depuis
plusieurs mois depuis 8 mois en tous les
cas on va attendre de voir quels sont
les motivations de ce coup-ci mais on
peut se poser la question si les
derniers attentats qui ont touché
sévèrement que ce soit des civils
et des militaires que ce soit assez
tanga
ou dernièrement la semaine dernière il y
a eu un attentat en début de semaine
lundi qui a fait adibo sur la route de
Dibo qui a fait
officiellement 11 morts et plusieurs
blessés donc on va attendre un peu de
voir quelles sont les motivations des
putschistes dans les prochaines heures
on aura plus de réponse merci Khalidou
et puis anges nominio étant en direct
avec nous bonsoir à vous ange la liaison
a enfin été rétablie je rappelle que la
connexion est particulièrement difficile
ce soir avec Ouagadougou vous êtes
arrivés sur place ange avec le reste de
l'équipe de France 24 il y a quelques
heures qu'est-ce que vous vous avez
constaté avant même cette annonce et
puis ensuite on reviendra évidemment sur
cette déclaration
alors nous avons constaté que la ville
était vraiment très calme il y avait
pratiquement pas de mouvement sauf à
certains endroits stratégiques ou les
militaires avaient mis des barricades
pour empêcher toutes circulations des
endroits stratégiques comme la Radio
Télévision
burkinabè et bien entendu au niveau de
la présidence nous avons ici constaté
que l'aéroport était toujours ouverte
jusqu'à présent maintenant que qu'elle
est fermée et bien entendu
beaucoup de personnes sont restées à
leur domicile il n'y avait pratiquement
plus d'activités et c'était ça montrait
effectivement les signes de de la
situation qui règne actuellement à
Ouagadougou est-ce qu'il y a eu des
réactions cette fois-ci en juste après
la prise de parole et cette annonce à la
télévision publique l'annonce de la
destitution du lieutenant-colonel Amiba
alors jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas
encore eu de réaction mais ça ne saurait
se saurait tarder il y aura certainement
beaucoup de réactions notamment sur
cette cette annonce de de l'éviction du
président Paul de l'ancien président
Paul Henri damibar des réactions
certainement de la population
civile puisqu'il on a enregistré des
manifestations
dans cette journée des manifestations
qui exigaient la démission du président
Polaris d'amyba ce dernier a été
critiqué pour la politique qui menait
notamment en ce qui concerne la lutte
contre le terrorisme améliorer également
eu des crises internes au sein même de
l'armée des crises qui liées le
lieutenant-colonel zonrana emprisonné
pour enrichissement illicite
également cette faction de l'armée les
mutins qui ont pris le pouvoir il
dénonçait leur condition de travail
puisqu'ils ont tout simplement été mis à
l'écart après avoir participé activement
aux [__] de janvier 2015 qui a vu le
départ de l'ancien président Roch Marc
Christian Kaboré merci beaucoup Angelo
mignon merci pour ce compte rendu depuis
la capitale burkinabè depuis Ouagadou
Ouagadougou merci beaucoup Kalidou si
voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour l'heure
sur la situation en cours coup d'État au
Burkina Faso le lieutenant-colonel d'Amy
by donc destitué ce soir et remplacé par
le capitaine Ibrahim Traoré on y
reviendra plus largement dans nos
prochaines éditions merci à vous
[Musique]